anger over vaccine inequality between
europe and africa cast a long shadow
over this landmark summit from the
offset less than 12 percent of africans
are double vaccinated compared to 71
percent of europeans but it's hoped a
new agreement announced on friday to
ship technology needed to produce mrna
jabs in africa will help redress the
balance today
i'm delighted to announce the first six
african countries that will receive
technology from the app to produce their
own mrna vaccines
egypt kenya nigeria senegal south africa
and tunisia
who will work with the companies and the
government in each country
to develop a roadmap for training and
production the announcement's been
largely welcomed but simmering in the
background an ongoing dispute between au
and eu leaders over vaccine intellectual
property rights many african leaders
believe that if europe is serious about
eradicating kovid 19 or indeed getting
rid of other serious illnesses then
powerful pharmaceutical companies should
share their research allowing african
scientists to make vaccines from scratch
in africa for africans
that's the goal said the french
president without making any firm
commitments
i think that the objective we should
pursue is that intellectual property
should never be a barrier to the
production and dissemination of vaccines
wherever they are needed that is the
objective
african and eu leaders have described
the summit as a fresh start with the
president of senegal maki sal urging
europe to shed colonial era prejudices
and to engage with a new dynamic
continent the eu's responded with an
economic new deal for africa in the form
of 170 billion array of massive
infrastructure plans to compete with
china's belt and road initiative what
this means for africa
is a new recommitment and a new
injection
of
european capital european funds to be
able to drive africa towards a
transition but also it looks at digital
transformation also look looking at
energy and green and also looking at the
environment and also things around
agriculture so it's a big big package
that energy is going to be a
big player in the whole of this new
relationship
55 countries and a combined population
of 1.3 billion people the african
union's long been accused of lacking
unity
of doing deals with foreign powers
separately and often in competition with
one another in many ways the pandemics
focus the african union's demands to be
treated as equals
reframing the continent as a place where
wealthy western countries are ready to
heavily invest
leave parker al jazeera brussels